okay
well
i did not get the job in new york
but i got the real prize
domestic bliss
jan made me breakfast this morning
well
she bought the milk
it's soy
this is why i do it
that's what i have to come home to
she probably won't
be up for a few hours this is going to
be a very good year
very good
jan is at home jim is back
my protege ryan is a corporate
good stuff
andy and dwight
are rocking the sales team i feel very
blessed
[Music]
i'm going in
why don't worry i have a heart out on i
could see that but yeah april document
this that can't work key to any
fact-finding mission is to get right
into the battle zone you know
it's like george bush when he flew over
new orleans or richard nixon when he
went to china to see what the chinese
were up to no
oh oh
oh oh
leslie are you okay
yeah
leslie hold on april's gonna get some
photos for the website can you just be
still don't move around as much
all right we got binocs camera night
vision goggles computer and
mini basketball oh my god i love that
my whole problem with basketball was big
ball tiny hands tiny ball problem solved
oop me ready ooping one two three
did that look as cool as i felt how cool
did it feel
at least once a year i like to bring in
some of my kevin's famous chili
the trick is
to undercook the onions
everybody is going to get to know each
other in the pot
i'm serious about this stuff
i'm up the night before pressing garlic
and dicing whole tomatoes
i toast my own ancho chilies
it's a recipe passed down from malone's
for generations
it's probably the thing i do best
that comes up from under the stage you
know like a rock arena kind of thing
they're coming
what oh
they're coming what time what the
russians
gotcha my leg
my leg you broke my other leg uh oh this
was supposed to be a safe event nothing
to see here except for the bone oh
sticking out of the leg
come on tough d jim
oh my god when we canceled on him we
took another gig in eagleton
at a library oh
that's literally the worst place i can
imagine okay guys we're not giving up on
this he's not the only musician in town
andy uh i don't know leslie i don't
really feel like playing right now
please please please please please i
don't even have children's songs my last
song i wrote was called sex hair well
just take the word sex and change it to
pickle pickle you've got pickle here
baby
and you got it from me
still sounds like it's about sex i'm in
i got to grab my guitar from my house
i'll be back shortly yeah see guys we
have a solution and and the good news is
there's always a solution if your
motives are pure and your cause is just
there's nothing
oh my arm
all right
heads up there's our perp looking all
purpy just purping his way down perp
street
take a picture give him one second this
slide is really unflattering for his
complexion it doesn't have to be perfect
tom olsen is a bad dude he's held up
four electronic stores at gunpoint and i
wish you hadn't read that annie
leibowitz book quit calling it a book it
was a visual journey you probably think
i should shoot this in color instead of
black and white yes shoot color why have
you been shooting black and white
where's he going now come on
damn it nypd free
[Music]
he's trapped
i'm tired of car foot chase my birthday
wish finally came true
i know i feel like the coolest person in
new york city
[Applause]
hey
pam
pam
hey
what happened i wrote you a goodbye poem
it's really long i left it
up in my office could you just please
wait till i go get it i should really
get going no
okay okay
um
the last word is seagulls
i'm sure it was really lovely i took a
lot from other poems
call me when you get in okay
bye sorry call
no michael
hey ann are you still a nurse or did
they fire you because you slept with all
the doctors do you want to try that
again
hey ann are you still a nurse because
andy's not feeling well what's wrong
andy just got a headache and i'm seeing
double and i got a song stuck in my head
and my teeth hurt also i'm hungry okay
well some of those things are symptoms
and some of them are just being a person
did you hit your head no
oh yes technically i did smash my head
area into the wall area yeah he was
hanging up his gold record
oh my god are you okay
yeah
i'm good
ah trying to pick the lock el capitan
that'll take at least three minutes by
which time i will have hidden this
plaque somewhere you will never find it
[Music]
voila of course you could break the
window but you would never knowingly
destroy government property would you
well mr had that one cheetah skate skate
like the wins
oh gina are you okay
let's go i'm fine ain't nothing
totally girl
you look good
how can we not watch this what happened
to do not mock we're not mocking we're
watching that will inevitably lead to
mocking so deal with it as it comes it's
the tape of me folly yes put the dvd in
quick time it starts on the song
trust me i've done this guys michael
can't handle this and as your boss i'm
saying we're not watching it no it's
okay watch it he can't fire all of you
what are you doing it's all right i can
handle it no i am a grown-up jim it's on
did they come
oh no
oh did you see that see what wait wait
let's go
yes you're right to stop it thank you
eject it jim you let michael fall in
play it again
oh
he purposefully leaned away and let you
fall
oh
man
i think when i started to see you go in
i think i just froze i don't think you
froze
it's a killer new dance move
do you want to talk in your office no
i didn't ask you
would you like to talk to me
judas
jim is my enemy but it turns out that
jim is also his own worst enemy
and the enemy of my enemy is my friend
so jim
is actually my friend
but
because he is his own worst enemy the
enemy of my friend is my enemy so
actually jim is my enemy
but
you know like when you go to the atm
and you get money is there an actual guy
standing behind the wall who slides
dollar bills in there
no yeah
this is robots oh actually you know what
i do have a serious question in a movie
predator
can you rub any kind of mud on yourself
to prevent predator from seeing you with
this thermal heat signature site or is
it one ow
that sucks are you hurt
oh no all good
all good
oops except for my mouth
oh whoa
five second rule
no
uh hey you guys i thought of a funny
response that terry's text from earlier
would you mind taking a look before i
hit send charles you've trained for this
moment okay we trust you just send it
come here
good job
all right i'm gonna do it
way to go
you